- C'était il y a un mois.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ
ministrexpérience
patient, puis c'est ce qu'on
veut pour les femmr les femmr l.
- Le ministre de la Santé
annonçait la fin du test PAP
traditio
progressivement remplacé
par un tpar un tpar un test moi,
le test VPH. Une nouvelle bien
acceuillie, mais qui n'a jamais
été transmise aux principaux
concernés.
gynécologue
- Oui, le gouvernement veut,
mais nous, on n'est pas prêts
sur le terrain. Donc,
le décallage qui se fait...
c'est un peu décevant.
- Et c'est l'enjeu principal.
Des gynécologues sont peudans u.
DRE CÉLINE BOUCHARD- Sur le ter,
puis il n'y a pas d'annonces que
temps prévu, donc c'est un petit
peu un ballon qui se dégonfle.
- Dre Bouchard traite des femmes
atteintes du virusaque
jour. Elle demandait l'arrivée
de ces tests depui
Malgré l'annonce de Québec,
elle croit que ce sera encore
très long avant de pouvoir
les utiliser.
- Je pense que ça peut prendre
jusqu'à un an, oue
début 2023 si on est chanceux.
- Le ministère de la Santé
et des Sciaux dit
vouloir définir le déploiement
des tests au cours des prochains
mois.
- Puis, les femmes nousdemandens
avoir le nouveau test?" Elles
arrivent à mon bureau : "Faites-
dis : "Malheureusement non, vous
êtes encore à l'ancien test qui
est moins sensible, donc détecte
50 % moins de lésions."
- Mais, selon Dre Bouchard,
le temps
Trois Canadien sur quatre
seront en contact avec le VPH
responsaquasi-totalité
des cancers du col de l'utérus.
Une femme sur 168 sera atteinte
ncer au cours de sa vie. taux
de mortalité de près de 25 %.
- Chaque retard qu'on prend,
il n'y a pas de séquelles, mais
pour cette patiente-là qui va
avoir des séquelles, bien elle,
c'est dramatique pour elle.
rapide, l'autre méthode
afin d'éviter les complications
liées VPH c'est la vaccination :
le vaccin Gardasil.
Mais le Québec vaccine
dans les écoles seulement depuis
2008 et à cette époque-là,
c'était juste les
Une dose du vaccin Gardasil,
ça coûte environ 220 $, et ça
en faut trois pour avoir
une protection maximale.
Les gynécologues militentcouver.
Ici Alexane Drolet,